vous êtes nostalgique de cette célébrité
de l'époque de chips non
bonsoir
salut Sylvain ça va
alors Sidney vous êtes né en 1956 à
Argenteuil sous le nom de Patrick Duteil
et c'est vous qui vous êtes rebaptisé
s'il n'est pas pourquoi parce qu'à
l'époque où j'ai commencé ma carrière
Patrick Duteil ça sonnait pas dans la
famille on se donnait tous des prénoms
américains s'appelait Kenny Dixon alors
que Dixon c'est Félix et Kenny c'est
Dominique et moi Patrick ça faisait pas
des massbia comme une génération de
famille de saxophonie il y avait des
signes des déchets il y avait des sites
né Poitiers à ces époques là j'ai choisi
ce petit prénom
à l'âge de 12 ans alors vos parents sont
d'origine guadeloupéenne père musicien
de jazz expert en biguine c'est quoi la
biguine ben moi Antibes
de base de toute la musique antillaise
des Antilles de tout le folklore
antillais la base c'est la biguine alors
en faisant vous perdez votre maman
cancer du sein ça se soignait pas pas
comme aujourd'hui alors quand vous avez
16 ans votre père vous demande de
quitter la maison et de vivre votre vie
comme vos six frères et sœurs il a il a
eu du mal à lever cette cause d'un coup
au décès de ma mère donc ça a pas été
évident et moi le petit dernier pour lui
j'étais un renard un petit peu alors que
je bossais à l'école comme tout le monde
et voilà par souci je pense par souci de
se dire tiens voilà je vais le mettre
majeur de suite et comme ça je suis
tranquille quoi c'est un petit peu à
faire comme ça malgré qu'il bon il
adorait ses enfants mais le souci de la
responsabilité peut-être voilà ça c'est
horrible c'est un peu retrouvé à la rue
mais malgré tout continuer vos études
jouer du saxo et de la basse malgré tout
vous passez un diplôme de comptable
l'envie d'y arriver je crois l'envie de
se battre de vouloir faire quelque chose
je crois que c'est avant tout ça et en
même temps de toujours toujours par la
musique donc il fallait que je fasse
quelque chose je suis retourné au
conservatoire de saxophone dans le 18e
pour pour la musique et en même temps il
fallait que je bouffe donc voilà et puis
les petits boulots heureusement je le
dis bien grâce à Dieu associé à mes
grands frères et aux femmes j'ai pu être
logé la vie d'artistes déjà alors vous
faites l'armée à Rambouillet vous donnez
des cours de trompette toujours la
musique dans votre vie le week-end vous
êtes DJ à l'émeraude alors c'est l'amour
c'est un petit club du 10e
arrondissement où il y avait Clémentine
Célarié il y avait Jacques Higelin et
Nina il y a vraiment Nina Hagen qui
venait à l'émeraude est venue peut-être
plus d'une fois il y avait des musiciens
dans coque les musiciens de Bob Marley
qui voulaient et on mettait aussi bien
du reggae que du funk que du de la salsa
je mélangeais toutes les toutes les
musiques noires voilà alors oui c'est
vrai vous êtes passionnés par la musique
noir vous avez tous les James Brown
ouais
dédicacé par James Bond on l'a rencontré
comment James Brown j'ai rencontré James
Brown par l'intermédiaire d'un d'un gars
qui faisait la sécurité pour lui qui
m'aimait bien et qui m'a dit il faut
absolument j'ai parlé de toi James Brown
comme quoi tu es le noir reconnu en
France il a demandé à me voir j'ai pu
rencontrer James Brown j'avais même mon
appareil photo mais je tremblais j'ai
pas pu photo avec lui et j'avais
toujours un album sur moi une pochette
donc il me l'a dédicacé à me demandant
attention
tu es dans un pays de blanc c'est bien
continue comme ça c'est très
impressionné voilà alors bientôt vous
passez au platine dans plusieurs clubs
parisiens au Rex à l'Opéra Night et puis
vous jouez du saxo dans un groupe de
jazz rock qui s'appelle mannshar vous
jouez du saxo et de la basse avec
blackwight and Co et vous enregistrez un
disque pour carrer lorsque deuxième
rencontre vous rencontrez Stevie Wonder
c'est énorme c'est énorme c'est un
concours de circonstances on était dans
le studio à en train de terminer à
l'album et il était dans Studio B il
manquait des câbles et bien sûr nous
tout fan qu'on est on est parti lui
prêter et j'en ai profité pour lui qu'il
écoute tandises qu'on a fait l'année
d'avant il a demandé à écouter ce qu'on
faisait dans le studio One écouter ce
que je peux jouer avec vous il n'y a pas
cru mais on s'est dit bah oui bien sûr
mais Stevie Wonder joue avec nous
donner rendez-vous la semaine d'après il
est venu à 4h du matin ils sont venus
installer les claviers et on l'a fait
James Brown Stevie Wonder
alors
ce n'est bien que vous connaîtrez la
gloire c'est d'abord la radio avec la
première émission de hip-hop à la radio
qui s'appelait rappeur rappeur Snapper
sur Radio 7 et c'est Marie-France Boyère
qui à l'époque dirigée Radio 7 qui vous
fait faire cette émission c'est magique
elle a demandé à Clémentine ou un des
animateurs de 7 est-ce que vous
connaissez un animateur noir pour faire
une tranche de musique noire de vin
d'une quotidienne de 22h à minuit et
Clémentine elle avait la main des
internets j'en connais un là il est fou
furieux
c'est tout simple et ça s'est passé
vraiment comme ça donc Marie-France
Brest est venue à la boîte elle a pas pu
rentrer c'est un club vraiment de Black
et la patronne était blanche par contre
la patronne blanche elle a dit donc à ma
France Brière qui est blanche non ici il
faut pas vaut mieux pas que vous
rentriez parce que dit oui mais je veux
voir le DJ donc ma France Brière tel
qu'on la connaît
elle m'a dit toi je te veux à Radio
cette voilà c'est toi là alors à
l'époque dans cette émission de radio
sur Radio 7 vous attaquez par salut les
frères et les sœurs qui étaient vraiment
notre slogan vous recevez Africa Bambata
vous faites du break avec les New York
City breaker dans les couloirs de Radio
France comme une fois que c'est marrante
nous à cette époque on découvrait en
même temps le hip-hop en même temps que
je le passais je passais de la musique
sans le savoir ce que ça amené un
mouvement donc je passais de l'électro
et l'électro fun qu'on passait était
mené par Bambata il y a une on envoyait
des fax à l'époque il écoute téléphone
corsaire Radio 7 et il y a une fille qui
m'appelle qui me dit attendez mais vous
passez du bain Bata j'arrive de New York
et Bambata est chez moi j'ai dit oui
c'est ça Jacques Chirac je n'ai pas cru
du tout et
bah écoutez si vous me croyez pas je
vais venir avec lui de suite j'ai dit
bah oui d'accord ok et c'est Laurence
twittou qui qu'on connait bien
maintenant et qui vient avec Bambata et
toute la tribu et là on est on est
accroché il y avait les danseurs Mr
Freeze qui était
et on a appris à danser finalement sur
le sol dans les couloirs de Radio France
pendant l'émission C'est incroyable
c'est extrêmement en avance
incroyablement en avance ensuite
Marie-France Boyard devient directrice
des des variétés à TF1 c'était HP hop le
dimanche en début d'après-midi juste
avant starskynetch
et là bon voilà proposé une émission du
premier mission que je vous propose à
TF1 c'est une émission nouvelle faut les
faire danser si mais il tombe sur le dos
là il va faire la France tourner sur le
dos sur la tête demandez ce que j'étais
capable de faire ça je découpe moi j'ai
jamais fait télé pourquoi pas on essaie
elle a dû abattre des montagnes pour que
ça se fasse et on nous a donné que 14
minutes et aucun budget pour le faire
alors l'émission est à l'antenne du 14
janvier au 19 décembre 1984 donc
effectivement c'est l'ovni du PAF quoi
il y a des battles de breakdance il y a
des leçons de hip-hop et puis il y a des
stars il y a sugarylang qui a fait le
premier message le premier morceau de
rap il y a Curtis et Madonna Madonna
c'était une super nana qui qui sortait
qui traînait avec les gars du Bronx
parce que là-bas et qui était déjà venu
avec à diverses reprises avec accompagné
des DJ comme dit vraiment les 10 premier
DJ celui qui se crache dans Rocky
dernière coque et tout ça donc elle
connaissait tous ce milieu elle est pour
moi
issue de ce milieu là et donc elle était
avec lui un jour elle a fait son disque
elle dit tiens parce que j'ai fait mon
disque pouvait me filer un coup
un coup de pouce en France pour pouvoir
pour promotionner mon nouveau 45 tours
holiday vous y pensez pas très hip-hop
mais bon on va le faire parce que c'est
la sœur des frères voilà c'est des
frères et sœurs voilà c'est un peu ça
alors James Bond Stevie Wonder madonna a
quand même c'est la célébrité c'est la
gloire c'est arrivé assez vite non oui
ça va très vite le végétaria comme ça
moi mon niveau c'est je m'y attendais
pas je suis plus un artiste qu'autre
chose et oui ça va très très vite c'est
bien en même temps et en même temps je
peux plus prendre mon caddie pour aller
au supermarché
c'est bon c'est le vétéria ils ont été
les réactions de votre entourage votre
père par exemple qui vous avez un peu
traité comme ça est-ce que il est revenu
vers vous à ce moment-là alors sa
première réaction est toujours négative
mais en fait c'est positif au fond parce
que j'aimerais bien quand même qui me
disait ça va il regarde quand est-ce que
tu passes à la télé donc ça va mais sa
première érection dit pourquoi tu
t'appelles Sydney et je vois pas le nom
de famille apparaître voilà les trucs
comme ça quoi bien bien auxiliés j'ai
dit bon papa tu veux qui écrit du tail
bon on mettra dans le générique Sydney
Duteil mais bon ça a été une bonne
guerre c'est pas et vos frères et sœurs
ils ont réagi comment ah bah très très
bien c'est grâce à mon frère Kenny que
je dois aussi dans le milieu depuis
petit parce que c'est le grand frère qui
m'accompagnait quand j'avais 14 ans
j'allais chanter avec des groupes de
rythme blues et tout ça donc j'ai pris
mon bien sûr mon grand frère comme
régisseur avec moi pendant parce qu'il y
a pas que la télé la télé engendre des
tournées des galets et heureusement donc
j'ai donc mes grands frères oui toujours
heureusement c'était plus facile
c'était déjà plus facile avant
non non tu sais ce que c'est si on a du
succès bien sûr plus il y a du monde
mais c'est pas ce monde-là qu'on veut ce
qu'il s'agit de la timidité de l'amour
on est des artistes c'est un sage et les
médias ça s'est passé comment contactent
avec les journaux les radios les
journaux ou très bien
Mickey match ça va mais bon j'ai
toujours peur un petit peu de mon image
une image de quelqu'un qui représente
toute une culture hip-hop je suis la
base de quelque chose donc voilà j'aime
bien que cette image reste là pour les
jeunes demain autour de moi ça se passe
bien et le pognon vous avez pris du blé
un peu on a fait du blé c'est comme tout
il y a des gens on fait du blé il y a
des gens on en fait
c'est plus c'est pas sur TF1 mais avec
les tournées voilà c'est pas là c'est
pas la TF1 qui m'a donné l'argent aussi
c'est de tourner les spectacles donc il
nous permet de passer un autre niveau
les impôts aussi
ça a été quoi le meilleur moment de
cette époque
des grands moments il y en a eu il y en
a eu plein mais je crois que le plus les
plus grands moments c'est quand on est
dans la rue avec tous ces jeunes qu'on
tourne qu'on tourne pas on est toujours
dans une sensation de direct avec
Gabriel coteau on est parti dans les
cités agréable la deuxième émission on a
tourné à la Courneuve où j'y ai habité
moi-même et ils avaient peur les
caméraman on va se faire piquer les
caméras et tout on était dans une
première voilà et c'est magnifique quoi
il y a des grands moments il y a eu des
mauvais moments à l'époque non il y a du
moment plus difficile parce que faut
savoir que je faisais une émission on
triait on avait beau trier les danseurs
les danseuses tout ça sur le un peu sur
le volet mais c'est pas évident parce
que c'est quand même on avait affaire
une émission vraie avec des jeunes de la
rue de la Cité et des fois c'était un
peu chaud un peu tendu heureusement
qu'il y a toujours eu du respect il y a
eu plus de respect avant que maintenant
et ça c'est quand même fait quoi les
choses ont pu se faire quand même c'est
ça qui est agréable et après qu'est-ce
qui s'est passé alors alors après j'ai
tourné une autre émission avec
Marie-france Brière sur TF1 qui
s'appelait Côte d'Amour en début 85 à
proposer de faire une grande émission où
on élargirait un peu on resterait pas
dans la culture hip-hop seulement on
ferait du rock on ferait un peu de tout
on était vraiment une grande équipe
plateau lourd deux réalisateurs
réalisateurs extérieurs et tout ça c'est
un peu je me suis pas senti bien j'étais
pas bon je me retrouvais plus j'avais un
courrier j'ai voulu changer de look et
ne plus être le même sorti du du Sidney
hip-hop tout en restant hip-hop et ça
n'a pas plu à mon public donc ça m'a pas
plu dit oui tu nous et puis les gens du
hipoles se sont sentis largués je
pensais pas qu'à ce point-là j'étais
tant un symbole symbole de la culture
hip-hop en un an de temps là vous êtes
revenus sur terre un peu quand même à ce
moment-là non oh oui vous êtes
nostalgique de cette célébrité de
l'époque de chiper non parce que les
choses doivent se faire en temps en
temps et en heure au moment je suis
plutôt pas quelqu'un qui regarde
derrière quelqu'un qui regarde devant
regretter que ce n'est pas continuer
quand même on regrette oui parce que on
se dit tiens c'est une situation on
avait su peut-être qu'en forçant un peu
j'avais rencontré Hervé Bourges qu'à
l'époque était dire j'étais femme dit
pourquoi vous êtes arrêté je dis
pourquoi vous me le dites maintenant on
continue voilà donc après
ouais ouais c'était à refaire qu'est-ce
que vous ne referiez pas pareil Sydney
être aussi influençable je serais d'être
plus dur plus dur pas avec moi-même
parce que je l'étais mais de ne pas trop
écouter les autres d'écouter plus ma
conscience si c'est à refaire on me
disant oui je le referai je continuerai
à chiper parce qu'il y a aucune émission
au monde actuellement alors qu'on est en
2010 qui a des budgets des énormes à
louer à toutes les associations partout
dans le monde à toutes les villes les
meilleures breakers sont français ils
viennent de remporter le championnats du
monde et
ce qui manque au PAF actuellement c'est
une émission qui concerne vraiment tous
les jeunes d'aujourd'hui sur le la
culture hip-hop et urbaine en général
bien sûr quand vous serez mort qu'est-ce
que vous voulez qu'on marque sur votre
tombe quel épitaphe vous voulez j'en ai
deux vous me direz celle que vous
préférez le Tchernia du hip-hop
ou le gourou du rap le gourou du hip-hop
parce que
comme j'ai demandé à être incinéré il y
aura pas de temps vous voyez qu'on jette
ça la mer c'est ouais bah écoutez merci
j'étais très heureux d'avoir rallumé la
lumière sur vous c'est moi Thierry et
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de Inna
larditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu